we're here in Toronto for the global
Championship I got Fabiana carwana with
me you don't need to talk yet I got
James we're gonna see who recognizes
these guys out of the out of the random
passerbys and we're gonna ask some some
fun questions about Chess let's do this
thing all right we're crossing the
street chess
no okay cool did you watch the global
Championship no okay do you know that
this is one of the capitals of the world
for chess for five bucks do you know who
this is
no okay active an actor well you see
this guy
any idea who he is somebody very famous
he is
this is actually 50 Cent's brother his
name is Daryl that's right goes by 75.
oh my gosh this is what we need
content on content beautiful
architecture here more approachable when
I say chess what's the first word that
comes to your mind
boring boring okay what about you say
chess what comes your mind challenging
I'm memorizing the movements it's a good
game king and queen I love that
winning the Empire wow that is ambitious
that's Machiavellian of you okay I love
that all right you're on Tinder you find
someone who lists chess in their profile
you swipe in right on that
yeah 100 no okay also okay yeah chess
players are boring and nerdy I'm like
interested in very like adventurous and
Adventure Fighting kind of person so
chess is boring but you're kind of into
a boring a boring mate yes yes yeah that
makes sense okay well I really do
appreciate you both letting me hijack
your conversation it looks super
important I hope you find the boring
chess player you're looking for you
Fabiano caruana is yeah he's right over
there okay so you know who that guy is
yeah have you ever listened to the c
squared podcast no never okay you don't
know that podcast yet no hey do you know
who Fabiano caruana is yes of course who
is he Grandmaster if you saw Fabiano
caruana would you recognize him
um maybe yes yeah maybe yes yeah yeah is
that him right there yeah okay yeah but
you haven't listened to the c-square
podcast okay Bobby you want to confront
him about that yeah you should listen to
it you should listen to it oh yeah no I
I definitely will hey T-Rex
hey
sir do you play chess I mean I played
chess with my son yeah yeah you
someplace yes yes why are you teaching
your son chess I mean you know I just
want to make sure that he learns
something where he need to sit Focus
mentally you're like an amazing Dad
thank you very much hey T-Rex come over
here man let's have a conversation
hey D hey do you play chess uh no I want
to learn when I say chess what's the
first word that comes to your mind mate
mate mate oh that's good okay you're
scrolling Tinder someone says they play
chess you swiping right
oh yes oh yeah they're smarter than me
okay they're smarter than you you're
super into it okay some would say T-Rex
little arms small brain not a good chess
player
uh BS all right T-Rex well I wish you
played chess but I respect that where
you were at in the food chain you didn't
need to use your brain very much yes
this has been awesome thank you good
talk it's T-Rex ladies and gentlemen
what about the players what chess player
do you know Magnus Carlson uh song who's
playing
I like Magnus okay I like watching the
boat test girls okay it's pretty
entertaining hey Carl okay can you name
another one Megan Megan nice make it uh
I mean yeah yeah okay I seen Fabiano
I've seen Levy I've seen Gotham chess
I've seen kind of like the main the main
focus sisters yeah those those guys as
well too if you can name three other
streamers I'm gonna give you five Gotham
Hikaru Megan his name is Megan I'm sure
Oh you mean madness madness Okay what do
you think this guy can kick this guy's
ass out if you had to guess it's not
lifting weights no it's not
ping pong quizzes the oldest board game
in the history of the of the human race
Tess
IE
what are you doing here how did you get
here
I was just playing at the park who's
running the company right now oh only
random people walking by not a lot of
chess players hey here's a random guy
hey man do you play chess
that's just you look oddly familiar you
sure you don't play chess you don't seem
prepared for this interview are you a
UFC fan yep oh so you didn't see the
global Championship not at the moment no
it was it was a big one a huge UFC event
here in Toronto oh that's great so who's
your favorite UFC fighter Nakamura
carwana khabib uh McGregor I mean okay
but Nakamura would have to drop weight
to go against McGregor but who you got
in that fight I think McGregor will win
I mean Nakamura is I mean Brazilian on
his back he's the best in the world if
we somehow made this happen Nakamura
drops weight class he's going up against
McGregor what do you think Nakamura has
to do to win that fight Focus uh more on
the skills first of all I want to battle
you guys I don't care if I win or lose I
just want competition hey there what are
you doing you rapping yes I am what are
you rapping about Toronto this guy is a
is actually a famous freestyle rapper
are you okay okay yeah we're about to
roll you can catch me on the mobile here
in Toronto in Chess at the global
championship and I'm feeling so rich and
you know I do my thing and you know I'm
so sick this is how I like to move and
you can't mess with this swish because
my last name's Gary like I was hanging
with a niche this is how I like to do it
and you cannot mess me and I'm flexing
because I'm so sexy that's all the words
I love it I love it yeah see Catching
Aroma jumps a competitive need
I'm washing the bed of my life for money
I gotta follow bars oh
oh he just killed him that was
ridiculous me as a rapper we just met
her yeah she was she was just freestyle
rapping and then she did her own rap
actually I I actually am a writer as
well so I write songs yeah I will write
raps as I'm good in that wearing a
hoodies all a crap from chess.com yeah
yeah okay so we got three celebrities in
the field we do we do was that fun or
what do you have fun yeah but something
I I never understood in in chess why the
hoes
goes right and jump what's the point why
why does the horse do that but they can
fly for a short period I think that's
the reason do you play chess at all yep
you want to have a small you know uh
like a game as if if it's possible right
now okay well what about what are these
guys here random dudes you want to play
chess okay so what is he a player or
something obsessed
he is a chess player I'm not but he is
yeah I play on the side yeah I've been
taking some coaching lessons from
Grandmaster Canty over here recently
over your calculation over everything
what's your name again sir uh my name is
Jamie what's your name
I already know it it's uh it's Daniel
yeah Daniel nerdinsky okay
there it is
on the attack baby on the attack if he
wins I know the guys at chess.com we'll
get him a diamond membership okay do you
know what that is yes okay is that
something you want yes yeah okay getting
a little spicy here okay look at you
look is this a London yo we got a pro
here with the London London how'd it go
what if I told you that the US champion
third highest rated player in history
was standing right with you right now oh
really yeah I'll be nervous you'd be
nervous right hey good game all right so
if you can guess which one of us three
is the reigning U.S Champion you get the
five bucks the reigning United States
okay
it's going to be at youtube.com chess
okay thank you so much hey there you go
what's funny is when he asked and he
said where's it going I wanted to lie so
badly what is wrong with me that I
wanted to do that I wanted to tell him
oh I should have said youtube.com
csq pod what is the URL of this YouTube
actually don't remember okay
the Sun is setting on the city of
Toronto
which means the Sun is setting on our
time here with the chess.com Global
championship
but Canada has spoken
and Canada wants more chess
so we will be back Canada
with more chess on chess.com
cut it cut it I can't I can't hold my
okay I blinked okay all right
[Music]
thank you